you are your own competition actually
that's true nobody's easier competition
to be the best version of yourself you
have to stop listening and caring what
other people think of you life is 10%
what happens to you is 90% what you do
about it
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message be the best
version of yourself over the Yuga workup
all das also if you want to know at
gorga paul das and others have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join it's in the description
below and it's easy to make a buck very
hard to make a difference when I talk
about self-confidence I talk about
trying to be the best version of
yourself you know they are constantly
updating our apps we can constantly
updating our operating systems whether
it's an iOS or an Android and the
updation of the apps or the operating
systems means to bring the best versions
of what exists and whenever you're
updating to a higher version of yourself
you have to be able to give the best of
yourself to it if you stick to the older
version you reach the plateau and you
don't have to work harder when you
update yourself to a higher version you
have to give the best of yourself in two
hundred percent of your energy there
yeah hard work coming out of the comfort
zone which is why many times I say you
are your own competition actually that's
true nobody is your competition that's
true we have to compete with ourselves
every single moment every single day
to get better than ourselves to get the
better versions of ourselves to get the
best version of ourselves so when I talk
about self-confidence I talk about being
the best version of yourself and having
that full confidence that I can crack it
I can get there real confidence comes
from you doing the thing that could make
you look weak it doesn't come by
pretending to be confident finding a
lambo in a parking lot and pretending
it's yours putting on a fancy suit and
acting as if showing off your fake
lifestyle an Instagram that is not where
real confidence is born real confidence
comes from doing the thing that could
make you look weak repeating it
consistently over and over again and
pretty soon you won't even remember
feeling weak so I look at my youtube
channel as an example when I first
started I was really afraid to get in
front of the camera I felt really weak I
had to have my sister or someone on my
team come in and focus the camera and
then step out of the room because I
couldn't make a video in front of them
then I remember filming for the first
time on the street and I felt really
weak really nervous really scared that
somebody would hear me and that they
would judge me for it and then the more
I did it the more practice I had the
lesson concerned me and now looking back
in making videos I don't care if
somebody's in the room I don't care if
I'm doing it on the street I don't
remember the feeling of feeling weak
because I've done it consistently over
and over and over again I'm trying to
attack it again now in a new form in my
tour I'm doing my tour of 23 cities in
90 days and I'm charging for the tour
and I've never done such a big tour
before and I've never charged for it and
the idea that scares me the idea of it
makes me feel weak and so I have to go
up and do it and as I do it I know that
I'll release the fear that I'll release
the weakness and that'll seem easy and
then that will allow me to do bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger things if
you allow this thing in front of you
that you were afraid of being judged for
the thing that you feel weak for doing
if you allow that to control you then
you'll never be able to bust through and
get to the next level and get to the
next level and get to the next level to
be the best version of yourself you have
to stop listening in
what other people think of you so I'm
gonna give you my three-step confidence
formula follow these three steps and you
will bring more confidence into your
life into your business and I allow you
to go off and accomplish those big scary
goals of yours here we go
number one what goal would scare you if
you failed think about it what big scary
goal do you have that if you failed at
it you would be afraid you would be
judged your parents would judge you your
friends would judge you you'd be worried
about what people would say about you on
social media what is that big goal that
big scary goal of yours that if it
worked out great amazing you hit a home
run you win but if it didn't work if you
failed you'd be worried about the
judgment write it down what's that big
goal number two commit to someone that
you're gonna do it tell your friends
tell people online tell your parents
tell the people who you're most afraid
of disappointing and letting down tell
them that you are going to do it commit
that you are going to do it their
expectations is going to drive you
forward instead of limiting you to stay
in exactly where you are
you need to commit to someone else and
then step 3
get to work you have your scary go
you've committed that you're gonna do it
and now you have to get to work and
newsflash you might fail and that's okay
that's okay all of the heroes all the
people you looked up to they have failed
and what you realize is when you fail if
you fail it won't be that bad the fear
failure is greater than the failure
itself the fear of the judgement is
greater than the judgment itself and you
need to go out and taste it you need to
go out and test it you need to go out
and start doing and that failure even if
you fail it's a small start that failure
will lead to more momentum more growth
and eventually a win so that's the
3-step confidence formula 1 figure out
what goal would scare you if you failed
to commit to somebody else that you're
going to do it and then 3 get to work
now I've got a really special bonus
video for you that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question of the
day I want to know what is your big
scary goal that you are afraid to fail
at let me now put it down in the
comments below
wake up it's a new day it's a new week
and if you choose it it's a new life you
get to decide right now who you want to
be you get to choose in this moment how
you want to show up in the world believe
that you're worth it
believe that you can believe that you're
capable of whatever you set your mind to
ask yourself how would the best version
of me live out this day waking up an
hour earlier and using that time for
yourself using that time to work on your
goal you have time you're just spinning
and doing something else success is
about choosing between what you want now
and what you want most imagine it in
detail see yourself eating the way the
best version of you would staying
hydrated if you are not taking care of
your physical body there is a 0% chance
that you're going to become the version
of yourself you want to be working out
dressing speaking to others looking for
blessings throughout the day the way the
best version of yourself would do it you
are creating your reality right now you
are the only person who is in charge of
what happens next you've got to stop
procrastinating you've got to embrace
right now and you've got to fire
yourself up to propel yourself to the
future you need to own what you do you
need to own what you do see yourself in
detail and map out the day in your mind
if you cannot be the person you want to
be right now in this second right now if
you can't make the decision right now in
this moment you don't have a why that's
strong enough and if you don't have a
why that's strong enough right now you
won't have a why that's strong enough on
Monday if you aim at nothing
you will hit it every time don't leave
today's version of you to a random
chance choose who you want to be choose
how you want to be then live today
accordingly well I'm stuck in a rut
because I can't seem to follow through
with anything I went to college for a
year and a half and I dropped out
then I went to cosmetology school I
completed that but I never went back to
get my license then I was a pharmacy
technician and I recently let that
license expire as well I just feel like
so many people that are my age and
they're already setting their careers
and I just feel like at 29 I'm a people
person so I want to do something like
mmm Human Resources and I just need help
like where do I begin first of all
you're talking about stuff that I can
relate to like so many others can relate
to I mean you know everybody got the
same story we just got different details
but like I always say life is 10% what
happens to you is 90% what you do about
it see we're gonna dive into a chapter
from my new book and it's chapter 1
section 1 this is very clear for people
so the first step is getting completely
and brutally honest enough to say I am
tired of myself when you say I'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired
that's the facilitator of change that's
when you're ready to say these words no
more excuses no more excuses I went to
Kent State I dropped out I worry and
drop out of flunked out now that threw
my life into a spiral but because I
didn't have a college degree I could not
let that stop me and like you're doing
were you saying all my friends at this
age are settling your careers you don't
even know if they happy or not stop
comparing yourself to others so the
first thing you do is stop focusing on
other people instead focus on being the
best version of you that you can then
you'll recognize that you deserve to sit
at the big table with everybody else
after you become the best that you can
be now once you've accepted that you
have as much right to success and much
right to succeed as anybody else
the next step is learning how to talk
the talk you have to get fluent in the
language of success so you speak it with
ease surround yourself with people
who've accomplished their dreams and
immerse yourself in the culture of
achievement and if you want more you're
Gopal das check out his fire
pieces of life-changing advice video
that I made the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there you
only learn to take and everyone has to
fulfill my expectations